l'asphalt vient tout juste d'être posée
côté gare de la verrière la route
réservée au tcsp transport collectif en
site propre est quasiment terminé la
partie asphaltée qui est la plus
brillante c'est réservé aux piétons
c'est non glissant à c'est pas parce que
c'est brillance existants la partie plus
large je vais être séparé en deux cd
voies cyclables pour la et puis la
partie entre les bordures en granit
engrais exactement sera réservé à terme
uniquement au tcsp la déviation actuelle
deviendra pérenne pour les véhicules
particuliers
du côté de maurepas le doublement du
pont schuller a pris du retard
un prolongement d'environ deux mois et
demi de travaux est envisagé lors des
explorations qui ont été faites
initialement avant le début des travaux
au niveau des culées des bombes n'ont
pas pu être décelée sur ces deux culées
de part et d'autre de la nationale des
pieux qui avait été installé il y à
quelques dizaines d'années en prévision
certainement déjà du doublement de ce
pont et il a fallu donc ré envisager la
une construction différentes et de
prévoir des micropieux un retard et un
surcoût près de 500000 euros de plus
pour cette partie des travaux
le budget initial était de près de 9
millions d'euros dont plus de six
millions de subventions de l'état de la
région et du département